[Music]
good morning everybody a long time no
see
pause before we start I wanted to say
this video was brought to you by
Squarespace
whether you need a website domain or an
online store make it with Squarespace
alright now we can go back to our
original programming oh we're just gonna
go get some coffee and then I have to
help you got my brother at the airport
the doors lock okay we have this
favorite coffee place that levo to in
downtown Mountain View and it's brand
new
oh we can walk through here too so break
[Music]
just picked him up from the airport
we're gonna get some lunch
how was your trip brick I'm the hella
tired alright so I thought I would do
like a 25 facts about me list we're
talking about something like random and
personal facts about myself if you're
interested in hearing about like how I
got into software engineering and what
my career path and college life was like
I have other videos for that but I
thought this would be like a fun list
actually there's 35 not 25 so here we go
I grew up in San Diego California I
don't know how to surfer skateboard
though until I was 10 I loved on the
East Coast and I moved around a lot I
currently live in the San Francisco Bay
Area I have a dog and a cat I'm Japanese
I can speak Japanese fluently I speak a
dialect from Japan that originates from
the Kansai area so I speak a Kansai Ben
fluently I Minicozzi an onion onion I
have a younger brother my favorite
subject in school was math until college
when it got really hard I studied
computer science
see San Diego I didn't know how to code
until I was in college I thought
programming was for nerds but I'm also a
nerd I'm afraid of birds
I like looking at them but I don't want
to touch them I laugh a lot too much
maybe nah yeah just the right amount
can't really see in this camera but my
hair is training grounds I get older I
was born and raised in the United States
I have terrible eyesight I used to have
braces but I did wear my retainers so I
know my teeth they're all crooked so
don't forget to wear your retainers I
love karaoke I have had a lifelong
obsession with Snoopy I like talking to
animals and pretending like they're
talking back to me I was in a frat in
college looking at the Sun makes me
Steve Madden posture syndromes really
bad I'm trying to work on it I cry a lot
when I get overwhelmed by feelings and
it's not pretty and my face pops up a
lot I also have trouble being
emotionally honest as other people I
think making friends as an adult is
really hard I don't like watching
scarier intense movies because I guess I
can try trains about that but my
favorite movies are your name and Kiki's
Delivery Service I'm gonna love hate
relationship with living in the Bay Area
I sleep a lot maybe I'm still growing
cool so I hope you like those 35 facts
it is now Tuesday the day before I am
leaving for Japan I'm working from home
today and I'm only two and a half days
my nose is also so itchy from allergies
it's funny cuz I know the kid everyone
around me like all my friends had
allergies and I remember thinking like I
wish I had allergies that's the thing
that I don't like I'm different because
I don't have allergies well I have
allergies now and it sucks and it's
painful and my nose itches so thank you
young when you go for wishing that adult
mice over has allergies because now I do
and I don't like it yeah I'm sorry I've
been pretty m.i.a lately I think I just
was kind of burnt out and it's not like
I was in a dark place or anything
like that it really just more felt like
I act like I was this balloon and then
just kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and then it just popped finally
so I feel a lot better now I've spent a
lot more time just to myself and I'd
haven't necessarily had any brand new
revelations about life or anything but I
do think that I need to have a better
pulse on where I'm at mentally and
physically so I've been giving myself a
lot more time just doing a lot more
self-care I was already doing some
self-care before but I think it just
wasn't enough I think I went from going
at like 30 miles per hour to 80 miles
per hour too fast
and what I probably need to do better is
just like incrementally speed up little
by little and then a better place now I
feel happier and excited and amped about
life it's also because of oil vacation
tomorrow but yeah I wanted to thank
everyone before your words of
encouragement when I was posting this
stuff on Instagram and it was really
helpful got a lot of Tears out and I do
feel better so thank you so much I hope
you liked today's video the format was a
little bit different than what we're
used to so let me know if you liked it
by giving it a thumbs up and leave a
comment down below letting me know how
you're doing higher 20 18 is going are
you doing self-care let me know and as
always don't forget to subscribe to my
channel by clicking the subscribe button
and also turning on the notification
bell to get notified for new videos and
before we go I wanted to say thank you
to Squarespace for sponsoring today's
video now when it comes to personal
sites I know that there is some pressure
to build it yourself you want to build
your own website so that you have the
skills to do so making sure that you
want to do it but sometimes it's not the
best solution sometimes you really just
need a simple solution because maybe you
don't have the time maybe you're in
school you have so many programming
assignments so I thinks where space can
fill that void really well they have
beautiful designer templates that are
ready to go and super clean super simple
looks super good for your personal
website and it's really easy to just use
them it's an all-in-one platform so you
don't have to install patch or upgrade
anything ever and that means less work
for you they also have award-winning
24/7 customer
servus so if at 2:00 a.m. you just
finish your programming assignment you
want to work on your website and you run
into a snag then there are customer
service reps on Squarespace waiting
ready to help you out it's also really
easy to set up a domain or transfer a
domain to Squarespace so that you can
brand it with whatever URL it's you I
personally really like personal websites
because they tell a lot more than a
resume or a cover letter because you can
link to projects that you've worked on
or talk a little bit more about yourself
and yeah they're really fun and I think
they're a great way to get your brand
out there and network with others so
head on over to Squarespace com to start
your free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace com /mo you go
we're 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain cool well that is it
for today so I will see you next time
bye
[Music]